Bonjour à tous,
aujourd'hui on va parler d'un sujet
que j'ai souvent évoqué
sans jamais le traiter complétement:
les inégalités de Bell
en mécanique quantique,
et en particulier les expériences
de violation de ces inégalités
menées par le physicien français
Alain Aspect.
Vous le savez sans doute,
en mécanique quantique
il existe un concept essentiel
et très contre-intuitif:
celui de superposition.
C'est l'idée que les propriétés des objets
quantiques ne sont pas toujours bien définies
et que ces objets peuvent se trouver
dans ce qu'on décrit donc
comme une superposition de plusieurs
possibilités.
Cette idée est à la base de
la mécanique quantique.
Elle fonctionne extrêmement bien
mais elle en gênait déjà plus d'un
parmi les pères fondateurs
Et notamment Einstein qui en a longuement
débattu à l'époque avec Niels Bohr
sans que les deux arrivent
à se mettre d'accord.
Il aura fallu attendre presque 50 ans
pour que les contributions théoriques
de John Bell
et les expériences d'Alain aspect viennent
trancher cette controverse restée célèbre.
Alors aujourd'hui je vais vous raconter
cette aventure scientifique
en compagnie, vous le verrez, d'un des
acteurs principaux de cette histoire.
[Générique]
Commençons par rappeler en quoi consiste
cette idée de superposition
qui se trouve au cœur des principes
de la mécanique quantique.
En physique dite "classique", la physique
de Newton par exemple, on s'est habitué
à l'idée que les objets que l'on considère
aient des propriétés bien définies.
Lancez un caillou en l'air, à chaque instant
il possédera
une position bien définie, une vitesse
bien définie, une énergie etc.
Mais en mécanique quantique, le formalisme
autorise les objets quantiques,
par exemple les particules,
à être dans des états
pour lesquels ces différentes grandeurs
ne sont plus forcément bien définies.
Et cela prend la forme d'états
que l'on peut voir
comme des superpositions
de plusieurs possibilités.
Il existe un cadre mathématique précis
pour exprimer ça
mais dans le langage courant
on le résume souvent en disant
qu'une particule peut-être, par exemple,
à plusieurs endroits à la fois.
C'est ce qui se passe dans le modèle
quantique de l'atome,
à un instant donné, un électron
ne se trouve pas
quelque part en particulier autour du noyau,
il n'est pas dans une position bien définie
mais dans une superposition de tout un tas
de possibilités,
comme s'il était partout à la fois
autour du noyau.
Et c'est vrai aussi en dehors des atomes,
de façon générale une particule sera décrite
par une onde, qui peut évoluer, se déplacer,
mais si jamais on essaie de mesurer
quelle est la position de cette particule,
par exemple avec un écran comportant
des détecteurs,
eh bien la particule va, en quelque sorte,
se matérialiser,
se localiser et apparaître
à un endroit bien précis.
L'onde de départ décrit en fait
la probabilité de trouver la particule
à un endroit ou un autre, ce qu'on appelle
sa "probabilité de présence".
Et tout se passe comme si,
au moment de la mesure,
un jet de dés cosmiques déterminait
à quel endroit on allait effectivement
la trouver.
Le formalisme de la mécanique quantique
fait comme s'il existait une forme
de hasard fondamental
qui interviendrait au moment
où l'on décide de faire des mesures.
Cette histoire de probabilité de présence
et de particule
qui se trouve dans tout un tas d'endroits à
la fois est assez difficile à se représenter.
Alors envisageons un cas plus simple
qui est justement celui qui va
nous servir aujourd'hui.
On va considérer ce qui se passe
quand la lumière rencontre un filtre
comme celui-ci, il s'agit d'un filtre
polarisant.
Et si vous l'utilisez avec de la lumière
naturelle il en filtre environ la moitié,
c'est-à-dire qu'il réduit l'intensité
lumineuse de 50%.
Mais au niveau microscopique nous le savons,
la lumière est faite de particules
élémentaires: les photons.
Or on sait fabriquer certaines sources
de lumière assez particulières
qui sont notamment capables d'émettre
des photons de façon individuelle, un par un.
Quand on envoie ces photons
sur un filtre polariseur,
on constate que la moitié des photons
traverse le filtre
tandis que l'autre moitié est absorbée,
on retrouve bien nos 50%
de lumière absorbée.
En revanche on ne sait pas a priori prédire
quels sont les photons
qui vont traverser et quels sont ceux
qui seront absorbés.
Et voici comment la mécanique quantique
traite cette situation:
elle nous dit que, pour ce genre
de source lumineuse,
les photons émis sont au départ tous
dans un état identique,
et que cet état est une superposition
moitié-moitié de deux possibilités.
La première c'est:
le photon va traverser le filtre
appelons cette possibilité "plus",
et la seconde c'est: Le photon
va être absorbé par le filtre,
appelons-la "moins".
L'état de chaque photon, serait donc au départ
un mélange 50% de plus et 50% de moins.
D'après le formalisme de la mécanique
quantique,
quand un photon rencontre le filtre,
tout se passe
comme si le hasard déterminait
entre ces deux possibilités.
En laissant passer chaque photon
avec seulement 50% de chance
Et là je pense que vous voyez en quoi
ce formalisme paraît un peu contre-intuitif,
plutôt que de dire que tous les photons
sont au départ
identiques et dans un état superposé,
pourquoi ne pas considérer
qu'il y en a la moitié qui sont d
éjà dans l'état "plus",
et ce sont eux qui passerons le filtre.
Et l'autre moitié déjà dans l'état "moins",
et leur destin sera donc d'être absorbés,
et sans aucune intervention
du hasard là-dedans.
Ce serait plus simple comme description.
En fait chaque fois qu'en mécanique quantique
on parle de superposition
et de résultat de mesure qui serait
le fruit du hasard
notre intuition nous dis plutôt que,
dès le départ, tout ça devait être
déterminé d'avance.
Par exemple si je tire à pile ou face
tant que je n'ai pas retiré ma main
je ne sais pas dans quel état
se trouve la pièce,
j'ai le droit de, provisoirement, la décrire
comme un mélange des deux possibilités,
pile ET face,
mais c'est juste un effet de mon ignorance.
En réalité elle est déjà dans
l'un des deux états,
ce que je vais observer quand je vais
retirer ma main est déjà prédéterminé.
Pourquoi ce ne serait pas la même chose
avec les superpositions quantiques?
Quand j'utilise la probabilité de présence
d'un électron autour d'un noyau,
on a envie de penser que ça décrit
notre ignorance de sa position exacte,
mais en réalité il est dans une position
bien définie, juste on ne sait pas où.
Cette vision, c'est en tout cas ce que
soutenait Einstein,
pour lui le formalisme probabiliste
de la mécanique quantique
était une description incomplète,
provisoire,
parce qu'on n'avait pas encore trouvé mieux.
Pour comprendre sa position on peut faire
une analogie
avec la manière dont on décrit un gaz
dans une pièce.
Je peux décrire le gaz en donnant
sa pression, sa densité, sa température,
et je peux même à partir de ces données,
connaître
l'histogramme des vitesses
des molécules du gaz.
C'est-à-dire que si je pouvais mesurer
individuellement la vitesse
d'un grand nombre de ces molécules,
pour chaque molécule
je trouverais un résultat réparti
selon cet histogramme,
avec certaines vitesses très probables
et d'autres beaucoup moins.
Mais utiliser juste ça pour décrire l'état
du gaz dans cette pièce,
ça reste une description statistique,
en réalité chaque molécule a effectivement,
en permanence, une vitesse et une position
bien définies,
indépendamment du fait que
je la mesure ou pas.
Il n'y a pas de hasard cosmique
qui intervient
quand je décide de faire une mesure,
c'est totalement prédéterminé.
Décrire le gaz en donnant juste
sa température, sa pression
et cet histogramme, c'est un formalisme
qui fonctionne très bien,
mais c'est une description incomplète
de la situation.
Il y a ce qu'on pourrait appeler
des variables cachées,
les positions et vitesses de chacune
des molécules qui sont parfaitement fixées
et qui déterminent exactement
comment le gaz se comporte.
Avec les variables cachées on a
une description plus complète.
Einstein pensait donc que la mécanique
quantique, ça devait être la même chose.
Il acceptait parfaitement le formalisme
et les prédictions
de la théorie quantique, mais pour lui
ça n'était pas la fin de l'histoire,
il devait exister une description
sous-jacente, plus complète,
qui permette de ne pas avoir à faire appel
à un hasard fondamental.
Mais en face de lui, il y avait Niels Bohr
et ses élèves
de ce qu'on a appelé "l'école de Copenhague",
comme Max Born ou Werner Heisenberg.
Et ils contestaient cette position.
Pour eux, le formalisme de la mécanique
quantique décrivait
tout ce qu'on pouvait connaître
et dire d'un système,
et rien avait besoin d'être ajouté.
Ce qui impliquait d'admettre cette forme
de hasard fondamental au moment des mesures.
C'est cette vision qu'on a regroupé
sous le terme générique
"d'Interprétation de Copenhague"
de la mécanique quantique.
– Au fond c'est un débat qui porte
sur la représentation
que l'on a du monde, Einstein
était un "réaliste".
Être réaliste, ça veut dire qu'on pense
que le monde existe
indépendamment du fait que nous l'observons,
et que ce monde a des propriétés
et que le but de la physique
c'est de découvrir les propriétés
du monde qui existe.
Et Niels Bohr s'est convaincu que
pour arriver à progresser
et à résoudre les difficultés
qui se présentaient
à la physique traditionnelle qui était
évidemment réaliste,
la physique du 19e siècle était réaliste,
Bohr s'est convaincu qu'il fallait
renoncer à imaginer
qu'il y avait vraiment un monde
avec toutes ses propriétés
et que la seule chose qui comptait ce sont
les propriétés que l'on peut observer.
Et Einstein pensait que cette façon
d'aborder les problèmes
n'était qu'une étape provisoire,
c'est-à-dire il ne remettait pas en cause
la physique quantique
telle qu'elle a été développée
dans les années 1910 et 1920,
d'ailleurs il a lui-même énormément
contribué à ce développement,
mais il pensait que ce n'était
qu'une étape provisoire,
c'est-à-dire que, certes on savait
décrire les observations,
que l'on savait rendre compte
des observations,
mais il pensait qu'une vraie théorie
physique devait aller au-delà
et nous parler du monde tel qu'il est,
et non pas seulement de ce que nous observons.
– Quand on résume la position d'Einstein
dans ce débat avec Bohr,
on fait souvent référence à cette fameuse
punchline "Dieu ne joue pas aux dés".
Mais quand on y regarde de plus près,
c'est un peu plus subtile que ça
car ce n'est pas tellement l'indéterminisme
qui gênait Einstein.
Pour le comprendre voyons
un des premiers arguments
qu'il a essayé d'opposer aux partisans
de l'école de Copenhague.
Considérez la situation de tout à l'heure:
un électron est décrit par une onde
de probabilité
et on place un écran pour mesurer
sa position.
Si on en croit l'école de Copenhague,
au moment où l'électron se matérialise
sur l'écran,
la fonction d'onde change instantanément
pour être zéro partout
sauf au point d'impact, on dit
qu'elle s'effondre.
Et pour Einstein, si cette onde
de probabilité est
la vraie description physique du système,
eh bien on a là une forme d'action
instantanée à distance,
dès que l'électron apparaît sur l'écran,
la fonction d'onde est affectée
immédiatement en tout point l'espace,
aussi loin soit-il.
Or vous le savez, Einstein est le père
de la théorie de la relativité restreinte,
celle qui dit qu'aucune influence
ne peut se propager
à une vitesse supérieure
à celle de la lumière.
On comprend donc que cette possibilité
lui posait problème.
Il existe d'ailleurs une autre citation
de lui,
plus complète, qui montre bien
cette préoccupation
Ce qui gênait fondamentalement Einstein
dans l'interprétation de Copenhague
de la mécanique quantique,
ce n'était pas tant l'indéterminisme
que la perte de ce qu'on appelle la localité.
La localité c'est en gros, cette idée
qu'il ne peut pas exister d'influence
instantanée à distance.
Il acceptait parfaitement les résultats
et le formalisme de la mécanique quantique
mais il contestait l'interprétation,
la réalité sous-jacente
à cause de cette violation apparente
de la localité.
Pour faire valoir son point de vue,
Einstein à imaginé tout un tas d'arguments
sous la forme d'expériences de pensée
et pendant plusieurs années
il a croisé le fer avec Niels Bohr, notamment
pendant la fameuse conférence Solvay de 1927.
Mais à chaque fois, Niels Bohr réfutait
avec brio les arguments d'Einstein,
ce qui avait laissé l'impression que Bohr
finissait toujours par gagner le débat.
Sauf qu'en 1935, Einstein est arrivé
avec un nouvel argument
qui cette fois paraissait bien imparable,
l'argument EPR,
du nom de ses trois auteurs: Einstein,
Podolski et Rosen
[Musique]
Dans l'article qu'on appelle depuis
"l'article EPR"
Einstein et ses deux coauteurs considèrent
une situation
qui est permise en mécanique quantique et qui,
pour eux, montre de façon indubitable
que cette théorie est nécessairement
incomplète.
Pour expliquer cet argument, je vais
en donner une version un peu modernisée,
inspirée d'une formulation que l'on doit
au physicien David Bohm.
Au lieu de ma source de photons
de tout à l'heure,
imaginez une autre source qui soit capable
d'émettre simultanément
deux photons dans des directions
différentes.
On peut cette fois placer un filtre
polariseur
sur le chemin de chacun des photons
et mesurer ce qui se passe.
Vous voyez qu'il y a 4 possibilités
pour le résultat global de la mesure:
Soit les deux photons passent,
c'est la situation qu'on va noter
"plus-plus".
Soit le premier passe mais pas le second:
"plus-moins"
Soit l'inverse: "moins-plus"
Soit, dernière possibilité, les deux photons
sont absorbés,
c'est le résultat "moins-moins"
Ce que nous dit la mécanique quantique,
c'est qu'il faut décrire
les deux photons ensemble,
et que, puisque il y a 4 résultats
de mesure possibles
pour décrire leur état initial
quand ils sont émis par la source,
il faut faire une superposition
des quatre situations.
Or une chose très importante dans
les superpositions quantiques,
c'est comme dans un cocktail on peut faire
varier les proportions,
ici on peut mettre des coefficients
à chacune des quatre possibilités.
Et en particulier, rien n'interdit
d'imaginer un état qui serait juste
une superposition 50/50 de plus-plus
et moins-moins
mais sans les deux autres possibilités,
c'est un état quantique particulier
mais parfaitement valide.
Imaginez que notre source émette
effectivement des paires de photons
dans cet état, qu'est-ce que
ça voudrait dire?
Eh bien, que dans 50% des cas,
les deux photons traverseront leurs filtres
respectifs,
et que dans les autres 50% des cas
ils seront tous les deux absorbés.
Avant de faire la mesure, on ne sait pas
laquelle des deux possibilités
va se produire
mais on sait que les deux photons donneront
toujours la même chose,
ils ont un comportement parfaitement corrélé.
Même s'ils s'éloignent l'un de l'autre,
c'est comme si les destins de ces
deux photons étaient irrémédiablement liés.
On dit que l'état dans lequel ils sont émis
est un état intriqué,
on parle plus généralement du phénomène
"d'intrication quantique".
Présenté comme ça, ça semble être juste
une construction intellectuelle,
une possibilité théorique permise
par le formalisme de la mécanique quantique.
Mais en fait, expérimentalement, on sait
le faire et on en reparlera,
on a des sources lumineuses qui fabriquent
des paires de photons de telle manière
que, quand on les mesure avec un filtre
polariseur de chaque côté,
cela donne toujours deux résultats
identiques.
Alors, pourquoi Einstein pensait-il
que cette possibilité était la clé
pour faire valoir son point de vue?
Si on en croit l'interprétation
de Copenhague:
la paire de photons est vraiment dans
un état superposé,
et au moment de traverser les polariseurs,
les deux possibilités sont encore ouvertes,
et c'est seulement à ce moment qu'une sorte
de "jet de dés" cosmique
détermine s'ils vont, soit
tous les deux traverser,
soit tous les deux être absorbés.
Mais pour Einstein ça démontre
que la description donnée
par la mécanique quantique
est forcément incomplète.
Imaginez que le photon de gauche
soit mesuré en premier,
et admettons qu'il passe le filtre,
eh bien ça veut dire qu'on connaît alors,
avec certitude, le destin de l'autre,
avant même de faire la mesure.
Pas le choix il devra lui aussi
passer le filtre.
Mais comme les photons voyagent à la vitesse
de la lumière
le premier n'a aucun moyen de prévenir
l'autre, de l'influencer
pour s'assurer que son résultat
sera bien le même.
C'est donc que dès le départ en fait,
le destin des deux photons était prédéterminé.
Dès le départ chaque photon savait
quel comportement adopter face au filtre.
Einstein en conclut que décrire
l'état du système en disant
que c'est juste une superposition des deux
possibilités, c'est forcément incomplet.
D'une façon ou d'une autre
chaque photon portait en lui
le résultat de la future mesure.
Il existe ce qu'on appelle
des variables cachées
qui prédéterminent parmi les deux
possibilités
ce que sera vraiment le résultat
des mesures.
Pour prendre une analogie biologique,
les variables cachées c'est un peu
comme si les photons partageaient
un même ADN
qui prédétermine leur comportement
face au filtre.
Cette situation, c'est au départ
une expérience de pensée
dont Einstein avait vu qu'elle était permise
par le formalisme de la mécanique quantique.
Et je vous l'ai dit, on sait, depuis,
faire cette expérience et ça fonctionne,
on est capable d'avoir des corrélations
parfaites
Entre deux photons émis par une source,
ce qui suggère fortement que,
au moins dans cette situation précise,
il existe une prédétermination du résultat
par des variables cachées.
Et donc, en résumé pour Einstein, s'il est
possible d'obtenir des corrélations parfaites
entre ces mesures distantes, et si on admet
qu'il n'y a pas d'influence instantanée,
alors c'est nécessairement
que la description donnée
par la mécanique quantique est incomplète.
Il doit y avoir des variables cachées
et donc l'interprétation de Copenhague
avec son hasard fondamental, n'est pas
la bonne.
Contrairement à d'autres expériences
de pensée imaginées par Einstein,
cet argument, en fait, il est quasi
inattaquable, le raisonnement est imparable.
Il est parfois présenté comme un paradoxe,
on dit le "paradoxe EPR".
En fait ce n'est pas un paradoxe
c'est vraiment un argument
que l'on peut écrire sous forme logique,
l'argument dit…
…le formalisme de la mécanique quantique
est incomplet.
Que s'est-il passé suite à cette charge
d'Einstein?
Eh bien, Bohr a écrit une réponse touffue,
dans un article que visiblement
personne n'a vraiment compris.
Il semblerait que, dans la tête de tous
les physiciens de l'époque,
Bohr avait une fois de plus répondu
aux arguments d'Einstein
et donc gagné le débat.
Étonnamment, les choses en sont restées là.
Pendant les décennies qui ont suivi
et malgré les efforts d'Einstein
jusqu'à sa mort en 1955,
la position de l'école de Copenhague
est restée essentiellement la seule
utilisée et enseignée.
Plusieurs facteurs peuvent expliquer ça,
les débuts de la guerre en 1939,
le projet Manhattan qui a mobilisé
les physiciens et surtout,
de façon générale, l'extraordinaire succès
théorique expérimental
de la mécanique quantique, ce qui n'a
pas trop poussé à sa remise en question.
– Il faut se rendre compte que la physique
quantique est quand même probablement
la théorie la plus fructueuse de toute
l'histoire de la physique.
Bien sûr il y a eu le mouvement des planètes
etc. mais finalement
c'est un sujet limité, la mécanique quantique
a répondu aux questions majeures
qui se posaient à la fin du 19e siècle:
Pourquoi la matière est-elle stable?
Qu'est-ce que la liaison chimique?
Comment le courant électrique est-il conduit
à l'intérieur des matériaux?
Comment la lumière est-elle émise
et absorbée?
Donc la physique quantique telle qu'elle
a été développée
d'une façon à peu près complète
à partir de la fin des années 1920,
a eu des succès faramineux.
Donc les jeunes physiciens qui entrent
dans le domaine apprennent
la physique quantique, l'applique
et succès sur succès.
Et puis on leur explique qu'il y a un débat
entre Bohr et Einstein
qui sont déjà vieux, et donc ils se disent
"ouais, il doit y avoir un problème
épistémologique là derrière,
quand je serai plus vieux, que je serai
à la retraite,
que j'aurai le temps de réfléchir,
il sera toujours temps d'y penser".
– Il a fallu attendre les années 60,
après la mort des deux protagonistes donc,
pour que l'Irlandais John Bell découvre
un moyen
de trancher le débat entre Bohr et Einstein
[musique]
Ce que découvre John Bell en 1964,
c'est un truc conceptuellement
révolutionnaire,
et qui va permettre de transformer
le débat épistémologique
en une question expérimentale.
Il montre que pour trancher la controverse
entre Bohr et Einstein,
il suffit de faire une expérience.
En fait John Bell a fait bien plus que ça,
il a démontré un résultat très général
d'une portée et d'une profondeur incroyables.
Mais pour commencer je ne vais pas
lui faire justice.
Pour faire simple je vais juste zoomer
sur un cas très particulier
mais qui suffit à comprendre comment régler
le débat Bohr/Einstein.
Et ensuite, je reviendrai sur la généralité
de ce qu'a fait Bell.
Ce que montre John Bell, c'est qu'il existe
quelques situations particulières
pour lesquelles les prédictions
de la mécanique quantique
sont incompatibles avec l'existence
de variables cachées.
Et donc, soit pour ces expériences
particulières
la mécanique quantique se trompe,
elle fait des prédictions fausses,
soit elle est correcte et dans ce cas,
il ne peut pas y avoir de variables cachées.
Ce que Bell propose de faire,
c'est de regarder ce qui se passe
quand on considère des variations
de l'orientation des filtres polariseurs.
Parce que, oui, je ne vous l'ai pas dit
au départ
mais un filtre comme celui-ci possède
en fait une orientation.
Imaginez que les molécules qui le composent
sont disposées d'une certaine façon.
Et vous pouvez donc faire tourner un filtre
autour de son axe.
Là, vous voyez, pour la lumière ambiante,
en fait ça change rien de particulier,
le filtre absorbe toujours 50%.
Mais donc aussi évidemment, dans
les expériences dont je vous ai parlé,
eh bien on peut faire varier l'orientation,
l'angle des filtres polariseurs,
et avec la source de photons individuels
que j'ai d'abord évoquée ça ne change rien,
quel que soit l'angle du polariseur
ce sont 50% des photons qui passent,
tandis que l'autre moitié est absorbée.
Par contre, ce qu'on peut imaginer,
c'est que ce ne sont pas les mêmes photons
qui passent aux différents angles,
par exemple quand le filtre est horizontal
et quand il est vertical.
Un indice de ça, c'est ce qui se passe
quand j'applique successivement 2 filtres,
par exemple si je mets un filtre vertical
et un horizontal,
eh bien quasiment toutes la lumière
est absorbée.
Ça suggère que les 50% de photons
qui passent le filtre vertical,
sont justement ceux qui sont absorbés
par le filtre horizontal, et réciproquement.
Et si je prends les orientations
intermédiaires,
on voit que plus les orientations
sont croisées plus ça absorbe.
Ça semble suggérer que le comportement
d'un photon face un filtre
va effectivement dépendre de l'orientation,
de l'angle du filtre.
Un photon donné va avoir tendance à traverser
si le filtre est à un certain angle
mais peut-être se faire absorber à un autre.
Si on exprime ça en termes
de variables cachées,
c'est comme si chaque photon portait en lui
les instructions lui donnant
la conduite à tenir si jamais il rencontre
un filtre ayant un angle ou un autre.
Genre: à zéro degré tu passes,
à 30 degrés tu passes,
à 60 degrés tu bloques,
à 90 degrés tu bloques etc.
Alors qu'est-ce que ça donne si on applique
ça au dispositif de l'argument EPR,
celui où une source de photons émet
des paires parfaitement corrélées?
Et bien si les deux filtres sont réglés
pareil, sur le même angle,
on aura toujours des résultats parfaitement
corrélés
Soit les deux passent, soit ils seront
tous les deux absorbés.
Ça suggère donc que les deux photons
d'une paire
ont la même liste d'instructions,
les mêmes variables cachées.
Bien sûr ces instructions peuvent varier
d'une paire à une autre
mais pour une paire donnée, elles assurent
que les deux résultats
seront toujours parfaitement identiques.
Ce qu'il faut s'imaginer
c'est que tout se passe
comme si les photons étaient des jumeaux.
Maintenant ce que nous dit John Bell c'est:
" Que se passe-t-il si on met les deux
polariseurs sur deux angles différents? "
A priori on va potentiellement avoir
deux comportements différents,
on a la liste d'instructions commune
aux deux photons de la paire,
et chaque photon va se comporter
en fonction de l'angle de son polariseur,
peut-être que l'un sera absorbé
et pas l'autre.
Ce qu'a proposé John Bell, c'est de faire
ça pour plusieurs valeurs des angles
et de compiler ce qu'on trouve.
Il se trouve que c'est une expérience
qu'on n'avait encore jamais faite
donc on ne connaissait pas les résultats.
Il s'avère que la mécanique quantique
fait une prédiction,
on peut donc déjà commencer par faire
le calcul théorique
Et voici ce que ce calcul nous dit:
pour un réglage donné de l'expérience
il y a donc toujours 4 cas possibles,
les deux photons passent,
on appelle ça plus-plus,
les deux sont absorbés, moins-moins,
le premier est absorbé mais le second passe,
moins-plus
et enfin l'inverse, plus-moins.
Dans le cas où les polariseurs sont
tous les deux verticaux, à un angle de 0°
on a 50% de résultat plus-plus,
et 50% de moins-moins.
Dans le cas où le 1er reste vertical
et le 2ème est mis à 45°
la mécanique quantique nous dit
qu'on aura 25%
pour chacune des 4 possibilités, bon, OK!
On va maintenant regarder d'autres
configurations des polariseurs,
et je voudrais qu'on se concentre
sur un cas en particulier,
celui où le 1er photon passe
et le 2nd est absorbé,
c'est la colonne +- du tableau.
Pour les autres, je pourrais vous donner
les chiffres aussi
mais on va les ignorer, on ne va pas
en avoir besoin.
Envisageons donc un 3ème cas:
c'est celui où on met un polariseur à 0°
(vertical)
et l'autre à 22 et demi, pile au milieu
entre 0° et 45°.
Le calcul théorique de la mécanique quantique
nous dit que ce sera dans 7% des cas
que le 1er passera et
que le 2nd sera absorbé.
Et enfin dernier réglage
dont on va avoir besoin,
si je mets le premier sur 22,5°
et le second sur 45°,
eh bien c'est pareil, la mécanique quantique
nous dit que ce sera aussi 7%
qui passeront le 1er et seront absorbés
par le 2nd.
Pour les amateurs, le calcul théorique
en mécanique quantique nous donne en fait
une formule générique en fonction
des angles des polariseurs,
je vous l'écris juste au dessus.
J'insiste à nouveau mais il faut bien
réaliser que ce que je vous écris là,
dans le tableau, ce sont, pour l'instant,
les prédictions de la mécanique quantique
pour l'expérience sur les paires de photons.
Quand Bell propose de regarder ça en 1964,
on ne sait pas si ces prédictions
sont correctes.
Mais bon, Einstein et Bohr étaient d'accord
sur le fait que les prédictions
de la mécanique quantique étaient bonnes
donc ça paraît raisonnable
de les prendre au sérieux.
Et maintenant voici la clé de l'intuition
de John Bell, il nous dit:
"regardez, il y a un truc très très bizarre
avec les chiffres de ce tableau"
Concentrez-vous un peu parce qu'on est
ur le point clef de toute l'affaire.
Admettons le point de vue d'Einstein:
il existe des variables cachées,
et donc dans l'expérience chaque photon
sait quel comportement adopter
quand on lui présente un filtre
d'un certain angle,
chaque photon a une liste d'instructions
et, pour les deux photons
d'une paire émise par note source,
cette liste est exactement la même
puisque les photons sont jumeaux.
Alors imaginons que je choisisse
le réglage 0°/45°,
et que je fasse l'expérience,
disons, 100 fois,
et considérons donc les 25 paires de photons
qui ont passé le filtre vertical
mais ont été absorbés par le filtre à 45°.
Je dis qu'il y en a 25, c'est en moyenne.
Voici ces 25 paires: je représente
les deux photons d'une paire ensemble
puisqu'on sait qu'ils se comportent
exactement de la même façon.
Et donc, ce que je sais
pour tous ces photons,
c'est que leurs variables cachées
nous disent:
"ça passe à 0° et ça absorbe à 45°".
Maintenant, posons-nous la question:
ces photons-là, comment se seraient-ils
comporté
si j'avais mis un filtre orienté à 22,5°?
C'est une question légitime, puisque d'après
Einstein, il y a des variables cachées.
Donc, même si on n'a pas fait cette mesure,
on peut envisager ce qu'elle aurait donné.
A priori ces 25 paires se divisent
en deux groupes:
les photons qui seraient passé à 22,5°
et ceux qui auraient été absorbés.
Alors à votre avis, il y en a combien
dans chacun de ces deux groupes?
Ben on ne sait pas mais on va envisager
des possibilités.
Pour commencer faute de mieux, coupons
à peu près la poire en deux
disons qu'il y en aurait eu 12 absorbés
à 22,5° et les 13 autres qui passent.
Donc 12 qui ont ces variables cachées ci:
passe à 0°, absorbe à 22,5° et absorbe à 45°.
Et les 13 autres qui ont
ces variables cachées là:
passe à 0°, passe à 22,5° et absorbe à 45°.
Alors, prenons les 12 paires en question,
encore une fois je les ai mesurées
avec le réglage 0°/45°
mais si au lieu de ça je les avais mesurées
avec le réglage 0°/22,5°
eh bien, d'après leurs variables cachées
elles auraient toutes donné le résultat
plus-moins:
à 0° ça passe et à 22,5° c'est absorbé.
Sauf qu'il y a un souci là, on sait que
statistiquement sur 100 paires de photons,
il y en a que 7% qui passent à 0°
et sont absorbés à 22,5°.
Donc il ne peut pas y en avoir 12 sur
notre expérience qu'on a faite 100 fois.
Si on fait abstraction des fluctuations
statistiques c'est forcément au maximum 7.
OK, admettons, pas plus de 7 dans ce groupe,
sauf que c'est pareil pour l'autre cas,
on a supposé qu'il en avait 13 qui passent
à 0°, passent à 22,5° et sont absorbés à 45°.
Mais d'après les prédictions
de la mécanique quantique
il ne peut pas y en avoir plus de 7 non plus,
qui à la fois passe à 22,5°
et sont absorbés à 45°.
et vous pouvez essayer d'autres partitions,
il n'y a rien qui colle,
on tombe forcément sur une contradiction.
Pour ne pas qu'il y ait des incohérences,
il aurait fallu que ces deux pourcentages-là
soit plus élevés
et que leur somme soit au moins égale
ou supérieure à 25.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire,
qu'on a fait une erreur?
Eh ben non, ces chiffres-là sont
les prédictions de la mécanique quantique,
et l'analyse qu'on vient de faire nous dit
que si c'est pourcentages-là
sont effectivement les bons, si c'est
ce qui se passe vraiment dans l'expérience,
eh ben on est condamné à rejeter l'hypothèse
des variables cachées.
De façon générale une théorie
à variables cachées
devrait forcément respecter une inégalité
entre ces trois valeurs du tableau.
Qui est que la case B plus la case C,
ça doit être forcément plus grand
que la case A.
Cette inégalité sur les valeurs du tableau
c'est un exemple d'une inégalité de Bell.
Et ce qu'on vient de constater,
c'est que les prédictions de
la mécanique quantique,
en tout cas pour ses angles-là
des polariseurs,
ne respectent pas cette inégalité.
Alors, je vous l'ai dit, à ce stade
on parle de la théorie,
si la mécanique quantique est correcte,
alors, dans certaines circonstances
elle viole cette inégalité
et elle est donc irréconciliable
avec l'idée de variables cachées.
Attention ce n'est pas le cas en général
des prédictions de la mécanique quantique,
la plupart de ses prédictions ne violent
pas d'inégalité de ce genre.
Le génie de Bell, ça a été de mettre le doigt
sur certains cas particuliers
comme celui-ci, où il y a une incompatibilité
entre l'idée de variables cachées
et ce que raconte la mécanique quantique.
Et donc Bell conclue tout simplement:
"faisons cette expérience".
Soit on obtient des résultats
qui respectent l'inégalité
et donc diffèrent de la prédiction,
auquel cas ça veut dire
qu'on a mis en défaut la mécanique quantique
ce qui serait quand même assez fort.
Soit on obtient ces résultats ou
des résultats proches
qui en tout cas ne respectent pas
les inégalités,
auquel cas il est impossible qu'il y ait
des variables cachées.
Or souvenez-vous, le raisonnement EPR
c'était de dire
"si la mécanique quantique est correcte
et que j'admets que la localité
est respectée,
alors il doit y avoir forcément
des variables cachées."
Et donc si on démontre expérimentalement
que au moins dans ce cas précis
la mécanique quantique fonctionne toujours
mais qu'il ne peut pas y avoir
de variables cachées
eh bien ça veut dire que c'est l'hypothèse
de la localité qui est à rejeter.
Le raisonnement de Bell nous confine donc
à l'alternative suivante:
Dans certaines situations,
soit la mécanique quantique se trompe,
soit la nature est non locale, il existe
des influences instantanées à distance.
Et c'est pour trancher entre
ces deux possibilités
qu'Alain Aspect a imaginé les expériences
dont va parler maintenant.
– J'ai eu la chance de tomber
sur ce papier de Bell,
je me rappelle très bien, le premier jour
où j'ai lu cet article,
j'ai dit "mais c'est sur ça
que je veux travailler".
Ça me semblait le problème le plus
extraordinaire
dont on n'avait jamais parlé, dont je n'avais
jamais entendu parler:
faire une expérience qui permettait de
trancher un débat entre Bohr et Einstein
[musique]
Pour comprendre les expériences
qu'a réalisées Alain Aspect,
il faut revenir un peu sur l'historique.
John Bell a donc publié son article en 1964
et sa contribution est passée
relativement inaperçue
à part de quelques chercheurs et notamment
l'Américain John Clauser.
Avec plusieurs collègues, ce dernier
a amélioré le théorème des inégalités
et il a essayé de le tester
par une expérience.
L'expérience était très belle mais
les résultats ont été mitigés,
parce que les barres d'erreur
étaient encore assez élevées
pour conclure avec certitude,
et puis d'autres expériences donnaient
carrément des résultats opposés.
– Quand je commence en 1974, on est encore
avec deux résultats,
celui de Clauser et Freedman à Berkeley,
et celui de Holt et Pipkin à Harvard.
Clauser et Friedman trouvent une violation
des inégalités de Bell
mais Holt et Pipkin à Harvard ne trouvent
pas une violation des inégalités de Bell.
Mais dans les deux cas, comme on l'a dit
tout à l'heure,
finalement le signal est très faible,
il faut accumuler pendant longtemps,
bon, on a bien l'impression
que l'expérience de Clauser et Freedman
est un peu mieux maîtrisée que celle de…
surtout on peut mieux changer les paramètres
que dans celle d'Harvard,
mais la question est ouverte.
Au cours de son travail Alain Aspect
a cherché à la fois
à améliorer la robustesse du signal
mais surtout à mettre en place
une astuce redoutable
pour supprimer une faille essentielle
de l'expérience qui la rend contestable.
Voici un schéma de principe
de sa première expérience,
on a une source qui émet
une paire de photons,
chaque photon va passer par
un filtre polariseur
puis, s'il traverse, venir frapper
un détecteur.
Parlons d'abord de cette source de photons,
on veut se mettre dans un cas où
la source émet les paires de photons
dont on a parlé dans l'argument EPR.
On veut avoir des paires intriquées,
jumelles,
c'est-à-dire pour lesquelles les résultats
sur les deux photons
seront parfaitement corrélés si
on les mesures
avec deux polariseurs
de même orientation.
Et en pratique ce n'est pas simple du tout,
d'avoir comme ça
une source de photons intriqués
qui soit efficace sans trop de parasites
et qui émette les paires une par une
mais un rythme suffisant
pour que l'expérience ne dure pas non plus
pendant des jours.
Et pour ça, Alain Aspect à amélioré
le principe
de la cascade radiative qu'avait
déjà utilisé Clauser.
L'idée c'est de prendre des atomes,
ici des atomes de calcium-40
et de les placer dans un état excité.
Quand ils sont dans cet état, ils peuvent
se désexciter en émettant
d'abord un premier photon de lumière verte,
puis quelques nanosecondes après un deuxième
photon dans les longueurs d'onde du violet,
et la nature du phénomène garantit
que les polarisations des deux photons
seront toujours parfaitement corrélées.
– Là c'est la nature elle-même, la façon
dont la lumière est émise
par cet atome qui va me donner
une paire de photons intriqués.
On arrivait à exciter spécifiquement
le niveau du haut
qui était intéressant pour l'expérience,
et une fois l'atome excité
dans le niveau du haut,
La seule chose qu'il pouvait faire,
c'était émettre la paire
dont on avait besoin.
Donc, source très pure, et puis surtout
on pouvait régler le taux d'émission,
donc on pouvait se mettre à l'optimum
c'est-à-dire une cadence telle
que les paires individuelles restaient
bien séparées.
Donc ça, c'était évidemment formidable,
ça a demandé beaucoup de travail,
disons que j'ai démarré cette expérience
en 1975
et que la source a fonctionné
cinq ans plus tard.
– Ensuite pour tester les configurations
où on s'attend
à une violation importante des inégalités
de Bell,
chaque polariseur doit pouvoir être placé
dans deux orientations différentes
Le cas typique, c'est zéro ou 45 degrés
pour le premier polariseur
Et 22,5 ou 67,5 pour le deuxième.
Ce sont ces réglages qui, en théorie,
doivent conduire
à la plus grande violation possible
des inégalités de Bell.
Dans sa première expérience Alain Aspect
et ses collaborateurs ont donc utilisé
la source de photons améliorée et
ils ont obtenu
une violation très nette
des inégalités de Bell.
Pour ceux qui connaissent un peu les stats,
la violation était de 13 sigma,
c'est-à-dire 13 fois la déviation standard,
donc truc assez incontestable
sur le plan statistique,
et bien meilleur que ce qu'avait
obtenu Clauser
qui n'avait pas une source d'aussi
bonne qualité.
C'était un très bon résultat mais
ça n'était pas encore celui
qu'ambitionnait Alain Aspect.
Pour améliorer encore la puissance
statistique du dispositif,
il a mis au point une variante du système
de détection de la polarisation.
Le système initial que j'ai décrit,
a un défaut,
il ne compte les photons que quand ceux-ci
traversent le polariseur,
s'ils sont absorbés eh ben rien n'est relevé
par le détecteur,
et donc on n'en a pas la preuve,
et on ne peut pas les compter.
Alain Aspect a donc mis au point un nouveau
dispositif permettant cette fois
d'envoyer les photons dans une direction
ou une autre suivant
leur polarisation mesurée, et donc de pouvoir
en principe compter tous les photons.
Ce dispositif amélioré a permis
à Alain Aspect et son équipe
d'obtenir une violation de presque 50 sigma.
– On met 4 détecteurs hein, plus-plus,
plus-moins, moins-plus, moins-moins,
et on va faire une expérience dont
instantanément
la statistique va être phénoménale
non seulement en nombre de sigma,
la violation des inégalités de Bell
par 40 ou 50 sigma,
mais le plus impressionnant c'est que
pour chaque valeur des angles
entre les polariseurs, le point tombait
sur la courbe prévue
par la mécanique quantique
à plus ou moins 1 ou 2 sigma
ce qui est exactement ce qui est prévu
par la statistique,
et ça c'est absolument phénoménal,
et disons qu'à ce moment-là,
je suis très sérieusement ébranlé,
c'est-à-dire je me dis:
"il y a pas de doute, la mécanique quantique
a l'air de très très bien marcher."
– Mais à cette magnifique expérience,
il manquait encore quelque chose,
l'ingrédient qu'Alain Aspect avait en fait
en tête depuis le début.
Car il y avait toujours une sorte de faille
dans cette expérience.
Toute l'idée de la violation
des inégalités de Bell,
c'est de montrer qu'elles impliquent
la non localité,
l'existence d'une influence instantanée
à distance.
Mais pour ça il faut être sûr que
les détecteurs de chaque côté
n'aient pas la possibilité de communiquer
et s'influencer.
On l'a dit, chaque polariseur a deux réglages
possibles donc il y a 4 configurations.
Dans la version initiale de l'expérience,
on choisit une des 4 configurations,
on règle les polariseurs à la main
et ensuite on fait l'expérience
pendant quelques minutes puis on change
les réglages et on recommence.
Mais donc, au moins en principe,
on pourrait imaginer
qu'une fois qu'on a réglé les polariseurs,
il puisse exister une forme d'influence
entre les deux détecteurs et la source
qui leur permettent en quelque sorte,
de se "mettre d'accord" sur les résultats
qu'ils vont produire.
Et ce signal n'a pas besoin
d'être instantané,
il a tout le temps de se propager,
le temps qu'on fasse les réglages.
Donc dans sa configuration initiale,
l'expérience ne prouve pas
avec certitude qu'il existe une influence
instantanée à distance,
il pourrait très bien exister un phénomène
inconnu à ce jour
qui expliquerait les corrélations
sans remettre en cause la localité.
Il y a ce qu'on appelle une "échappatoire",
l'échappatoire de localité.
Pour démontrer le truc avec certitude,
ce qu'il faut c'est
que les détecteurs n'aient pas le temps
de pouvoir se communiquer leurs réglages,
c'est-à-dire que le choix de l'orientation
des polariseurs soit fait
après l'émission des photons par la source.
C'est d'ailleurs quelque chose que Bell
avait déjà en tête,
et pour lui aussi c'était un élément crucial
pour que l'expérience soit valable.
– Quand on lit bien Einstein
et qu'on lit bien Bell,
le fameux papier de 1964, dans ces hypothèses
il faut dire
que la détection d'un côté et la détection
de l'autre côté sont indépendantes,
ne peuvent pas conspirer entre elles.
Conspirer c'est une façon de dire
qu'il y a une interaction.
Et comme Bell l'avait suggéré dès son papier
de 1964, moi mon objectif,
c'était d'empêcher tout possibilité
de conspiration
en choisissant au dernier moment
l'orientation du polariseur
qui est de ce côté-ci, de telle sorte
que l'autre qui est là,
ne "sais pas" au moment de la mesure
quelle est l'orientation de celui-ci
et on bloque ainsi toute possibilité
de conspiration.
– Alors très bien amusons nous à choisir
et changer l'orientation du polariseur
pendant que les photons sont en train
de se propager.
Sauf que c'est un truc de malade
ce qu'on est en train de dire là,
regardons le timing que ça implique.
Dans l'expérience d'Alain Aspect,
il y avait environ 6 mètres
entre la source et chaque détecteur.
Il fallait donc seulement 20 nanoseconde
à un photon pour franchir cette distance,
ça veut dire qu'entre le moment où il quitte
la source et son arrivée,
on a 20 nanosecondes pour décider
de l'orientation du polariseur.
Ça parait évidemment impossible
qu'une personne tourne le polariseur
à la main pendant cet intervalle de temps.
Pour faire ça, Alain Aspect a imaginé
un dispositif
très astucieux à base d'ondes acoustiques
stationnaires dans une cuve d'eau,
et capable de dévier le faisceau dans
une direction ou une autre.
En plaçant un polariseur avec une orientation
dans une direction
et un autre polariseur avec la deuxième
orientation dans l'autre,
c'est comme si on pouvait changer le réglage
et la fréquence des oscillations était telle
que les variations pouvaient avoir lieu
toutes les 10 nanosecondes.
– Et on était là et on regardait en temps
réel la statistique se construire.
Et, eh ben il n'y avait aucun doute,
même en basculant très vite les polariseurs,
on continuait à violer les inégalités de Bell,
je me rappelle très bien.
– Grâce à ce dispositif, Alain Aspect
et ses collaborateurs ont pu réaliser
une expérience de violation des inégalités
de Bell dans sa forme la plus pure,
celle où l'on varie l'orientation
des polariseurs
pendant le temps de vol des photons,
techniquement on dit qu'ils ont fermé
l'échappatoire de localité.
Cette expérience de violation a permis
de véritablement trancher
le débat Bohr/Einstein.
En prouvant que d'une part les prédictions
de la mécanique quantique
fonctionnent toujours dans ce type
d'expérience extrême,
ce qui n'était pas forcément gagné,
et d'autre part que cela implique
qu'aucune théorie à variables cachées
ne peut expliquer ces résultats-là.
Et que donc l'hypothèse de localité
si chère à Einstein est fausse,
au moins dans ces cas-là la nature
se comporte de façon non locale.
Il existe des formes d'influence instantanée
à distance entre des particules intriquées.
C'est fou non?
[musique]
Pour mettre ses extraordinaires résultats
en perspective
je voudrais revenir sur plusieurs points.
D'abord j'ai dit que ce qu'avait montré Bell
était un truc très général
et je vous ai présenté seulement
un cas très très particulier,
une inégalité pour un problème spécifique
de photons et de polariseurs.
En fait dans sa forme la plus aboutie
qu'il a publiée en 1976,
Bell a démontré une inégalité générique
qui s'applique aux théories
qui respectent ce qu'on appelle
la causalité locale,
et on n'a pas besoin de parler de photons
ni même de mécanique quantique.
Bell nous dit: prenez une expérience
pour laquelle vous faites des mesures
dans 2 régions distantes de l'espace
et pour laquelle
chaque mesure peut avoir deux réglages:
a et a'd'un côté, b et b'de l'autre.
Compiler les pourcentages dans un tableau,
et, si la nature est locale
ces pourcentages doivent nécessairement
satisfaire une certaine inégalité.
Et ce que Bell démontre de façon
tout à fait générale,
c'est que les théories locales
sont intrinsèquement limitées,
elles ne peuvent pas tout.
Une autre précision très importante
que je dois faire,
c'est que j'ai utilisé tout du long
l'expression "variables cachées"
pour ce qu'on doit appeler en toute rigueur
des "variables cachées locales".
Avec le théorème de Bell, ce que montrent
les expériences d'Alain Aspect
c'est que la nature est non locale,
mais ça ne dit rien en fait
de la question du déterminisme
et de l'indéterminisme.
Une façon grossière de résumer ces résultats,
ce serait de dire que
John Bell et Alain Aspect ont montré que Bohr
avait raison et Einstein avait tort.
Mais en fait c'est plus compliqué que ça,
Einstein avait clairement tort sur un point,
sur sa croyance indéfectible
que la nature est locale.
Mais stricto sensu, c'est tout ce qu'on peut
conclure des expériences d'Alain Aspect,
ça ne prouve pas que la mécanique quantique
est complète
ou qu'une forme fondamentale de hasard
existe forcément.
Il peut quand même exister
des variables cachées
qui prédisent les résultats de façon
déterministe,
mais ces variables cachées doivent
alors forcément être non locales.
Il existe d'ailleurs une interprétation
de la mécanique quantique,
celle de l'onde pilote de De Broglie-Bohm
qui s'affranchit du hasard à l'aide
de variables cachées non locales.
Il faudrait que je fasse un épisode
sur cette interprétation un jour.
Le dernier point qu'il faut préciser c'est
qu'après les expériences d'Alain Aspect,
d'autres variantes ont encore amélioré
le résultat
soit en augmentant les distances ou
en fermant d'autres échappatoires
comme ce qu'on appelle l'échappatoire
de détection.
Il s'agit d'échappatoires beaucoup plus
tirées par les cheveux
et auxquelles personne ne croyait vraiment
contrairement à l'échappatoire de localité.
Mais ce sont d'autres d'échappatoire qui,
sur le papier,
restent des points faibles de l'expérience,
et ça n'est finalement qu'en 2015
qu'on a annoncé les premières expériences
qui était supposément dénuées
de toute échappatoire.
Un point historique intéressant sur
ces expériences de violation
des inégalités de Bell, c'est qu'elles ont
pu véritablement démontrer
la réalité du phénomène d'intrication,
cette sorte de connexion intime qui peut
subsister entre des paires de particules
même quand on les éloigne sur
des distances importantes.
Et aujourd'hui, parmi les applications
de ce phénomène
eh bien il y a l'ordinateur quantique
et les techniques de communication
et de cryptographie quantique.
Comme quoi un sujet de recherche
ultra fondamentale, presque philosophique
et sans aucune perspective d'application,
a pu devenir 30 ans plus tard un des sujets
technologiques les plus chaud du moment.
Et oui, comme souvent, ça n'est pas
en se focalisant
sur les répercussions industrielles
à court terme
qu'on produit les applications technologiques
les plus intéressantes.
Les chemins de la recherche sont pleins
de détours et de surprise
et la recherche fondamentale d'aujourd'hui,
ce sont peut-être les applications de demain,
ne l'oublions pas.
Merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo,
si vous voulez en savoir plus,
je vais publier très prochainement
l'interview complète
que j'ai eu la chance et le plaisir
de faire avec Alain Aspect.
Pour des détails techniques notamment
sur les inégalités de Bell
je vous renvoie au billet de blog
qui accompagne comme toujours la vidéo.
Si vous avez tenu jusque-là, c'est vraiment
que vous étiez motivés, bravo!
Alors n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
si ce n'est pas le cas,
activer la cloche, mettre un pouce, tout ça,
ça permet de me soutenir et de m'encourager.
Les actualités de la chaîne ça se passe
sur Facebook et Twitter
et puis on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle vidéo.
À bientôt!
– Sous-titrage: Le Crayon d'oreille -